è una cosa che noi negli anni 90 lo
facciamo mai non si fa perché proprio
sbagliato che riguardare il video di
quando ballavamo la tectonic la seconda
cosa che non facciamo e controllare e
ricontrollare i vecchi post su facebook
più perché le persone di cultura anche
se oggi possono sembrare persone a modo
insomma io mi reputo un ragazzo
abbastanza intelligente ma neanche
adesso è rotta però ai tempi c'era un po
di provincia non delle problematiche e
andiamo a scoprirle allora allora non vi
permettete perché tutti quanti avete
fatto cagare tempo fa su facebook e con
i post ripete tutti quanti nessuno
escluso
calmi e taider boni ormai sdoganato la
mia ormai non sono più neanche il nome
ne frega più niente chi se ne frega
dignità ormai cielo sotto hai fatto
anche video dove vado just dance
il mio primo post su facebook è stato io
a il manifesto min già raid raid non è
con il player inside e nel mio
personaggio preferito di metal gear
solid questa è la mia prima pasta ancora
umile ancora umile attenzione 3 febbraio
2009 che personaggi di dragon ball 6 ma
questo fa niente
io sono uscito come personaggio di drago
per forse krill il primo posto che mi
fanno sulla bacheca c'è lorenzo anche tu
su facebook pacione mia cugina mettiamo
mi piace quindi a questo era il
compleanno mio compleanno mi facevano
gli auguri a lorenzo e mia cugina auguri
buon compleanno
questa un'altra mia cugina tutti i
nemici bene così come la pigrizia
l'abbiamo fusa nella mia anima già i
tempi in tutt'uno già ai tempi non avevo
sbatti limete mi piace ogni commento
eccetera
e allora ho scritto generalizzando
grazie a tutti per gli auguri
comunque andiamo avanti ragazzi tanto
guarda c'è lorenzo come va allo studio
per gli esami male male cugina malissimo
quiz quanto mi conosci vorrei fare
questi qui oggi ovviamente non esistono
più peccato perché proprio peccato mi ha
avvantaggiato viene attaccato in quei
posti che facevano quando finisce la
scuola e quindi tutte quelle cagati né
tipo tanta un tuo amico doug al tuo
parente un pagliaccio il tag è la
persona che ti fa più ridere io
probabilmente ero compagnia di base
no tav e apprezzato miei capelli non ero
io sicuramente perfetta il miglior amico
le elementari o grazie marco
l'attenzione ragazzi abbiamo un grazie
raga in risposta agli auguri di buon
compleanno insomma hanno fatto anche due
volte perché la prima volta l'ho fatto
prima al giorno prima poi l'ho fatto il
giorno dopo per avere un non so due
volte vedi ringraziamenti incredibili
attenzione qua mio padre pubblica una
foto e avrei preferito che non l'avesse
pubblicata ma fa niente se il compleanno
attenzione ci sono un sacco di bambine
dolci e poi ci sono io con la torta di
doremi però vabbè grazie papà purtroppo
non sono riuscito a scoprire come
rimuovere i post dal diario era troppo
ero troppo ingenuo mi ha precluso un
sacco di cose sta roba qua profondità e
migliore amica lì con dvd video di frank
matano aidepi io andavo pazzo per frank
matano rap tutti in realtà quindi pazzo
pazzo pazzo pazzo che riguardavano
frequentano fino a a sapere i video a
memoria rom incredibile ciao franco un
bacio
ti saluto tanto mi aveva anche disposto
un commento ero gasatissimo siamo finiti
a fare le gare sulle macchinine
elettriche drom la vita è questa ragazzi
un giorno condividi i video del tuo
youtuber preferito il giorno dopo ti
ritrovi a farci le gare sulle macchinine
attenzione questo bellissimo un mio
amico su facebook mi scrive ciao lori a
caso e io gli ho messo mi piace però
dopo tre anni chi vuole 2013 euro mi
piace ma che cazzo commenta melo dopo
tre anni a noi hanno commentato ciao
andrea più dopo tre anni di lavoro
mentale ma che cazzo commentavano dopo
tre anni tg1 visto adesso vede gli
ottavi che mai ma tanto tardi
eh sì perfetto ragazza ogni dieci anni
ci voglia un messaggio bellissimo
ciao andrea ci rivediamo nel 2030
attenzione attenzione di un post di gesù
cristo
non so per quale motivo in realtà per
quale motivo in ciò che c'era la
descrizione niente panico
sta solo facendo stretching e mi faceva
ridere
niente condiviso sta cosa chi ha un bel
usavano al 100 alzi la mano
e c'era il papà mi faceva ridere anche
gesù dietro ma perché è sempre gesù
basta ma basta gesù no non è vero questo
non posso essere stato io sicuramente è
stata mia madre possa aver condiviso la
foto di un cucciolo di cane il mio
cervello non poteva essere così
deformato i tempi justin bieber usa
canto ma fallisce
[Musica]
io non so se il milan non sono uscirò
togliete facebook a questa persona vi
prego feto ero turistico e mia zia sono
proprio vecchia tranquilla zia non è
rituale se è troppo vecchia eroi ad
essere troppo rincoglionito ma vaglielo
a spiegare a lei per le migliori frasi
de die d'appari senso ci può senza
picanto a si mangi qui porti via perché
limitano amiche bari da bambina per
quale motivo poi comunque mai chiqui
porti via rimasto ma ai cinque porti via
ma perché continua continua a
condividere questo post fa basta
iniziato parla come kebabari scherzo
passate in paese la morire dal ridere
meno male non esiste più
beh ve lo faccio vedere c'è una stomia
compagno aprite c'era questo tappeto in
palestra che già sto tappeto che era
negli spogliatoi ma è questo sono in
questo in basso si sta con la maglia
viola sono io
coach è un mio amico e tutti quanti
venivano a tutti quanti arrivavano
dentro lo spogliatoio e si buttavano sul
tappeto ok farti vedere la gente che si
mette sul tappeto e ci passa sopra a
riesce a puntare il nostro compagno si
lanciano li soddisfa gli spostiamo
questo attirato una panciata non va
fortissimo
porca vacca e botta che sarà la nostra
vita scuola bellissima domani e lunedì
no ma perché ma poi tanto siamo già nel
2011 fine anno passato un sacco di anni
dall'iscrizione di facebook ma perché
perché lorenzo perché tensione tensione
tensione fun mode gesù e co
ai tempi di facebook ipantellas perché
io ero anche un big ben
bravi ha proposto sempre sul pezzo mi
piacevano un sacco ipantellas cioè mi
piace un sacco
non parliamo al passato vi piacciono è
che chi strano che poi che pensa che
casino la vita che siamo finiti a fare
poi evidenzia come è possibile st cagata
l'avevo scritta con la gomma
semplicemente perché quando tu cancelli
con la gomma che rimangono i pezzettini
commessi tutti se abbiamo fatto sta
scritta e da qui nacque sennò questo
nickname avevo già da tipo 67 anni però
d'acqua inizia la prima apparizione sul
web di questo nickname è questa
eccolo eccolo il trash che volevo e
questo è che palle perché non è arrivato
prima stavo post mio posto io stavo
sognando di un angelo caduto dal cielo
ma di che cazzo
parliamo cioè nel senso allora ti spiego
però stavo tornando a casa da scuola no
con la sull'autobus è un certo punto su
questa auto so visto una tipa bellissima
bellissima cioè bellissima da dei bei
lineamenti noi quella quella ragazza che
ti gira con la dc mamma mia che pezzo di
gnocco perché a me in realtà non è che
mi faccia impazzire la mente c'è una
ragazza più graziose eccetera
e questa era veramente bella bella ma
proprio wow è niente questo è arrivato a
caso il kit st cagata questa ve la leggo
rega ve la leggo serata al bar questa
vera serata al bar di due ragazze bionde
kissi me mi fissano e parlano tra di
loro dopo una si avvicina me e fa
esclusiva per le fans e io voi siete il
game 7 voler limone e mia madre di pura
cattiveria risponde no pero in vacanza
cell al bar dell'hotel ero sceso con mia
mamma mi ero seduto con mia mamma
c'ero io ce la mia madre c'erano state
due francesi una [ __ ] dal tocco in [ __ ]
arrivano le scuse ma per le france e mia
madre
no abbiamo allora più di così veramente
ho messo a nudo il mio facebook c'è
veramente da morirci
io non voglio più vedere provvede il
genere nella mia vita
noi avete sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa mi
piace iscritti al che me l'ha
schiacciata campanellina primati
raggiunti siano divide che non me li
volete perdere video come questi
figurano è come sempre scia al prossimo
video bello ragazzo
[Musica]
no